Stop it. I don't want to do this.
Don't ever fucking tell me that I don't do that.
I don't know. I'm sorry.
Thank you.
I'm the one that suggested it.
No more, TVG.
No, seriously. I'm the one that suggested it.
No more. No more.
Have you seen my eyes?
Huh?
That's not my problem.
It's not your problem.
That's why I'm telling you.
Stop it.
You're the one with the anger issue.
No, seriously.
Ricky, please.
I don't want to discuss this.
Okay?
Exactly.
That's exactly the fucking issue.
And not only do you not want to discuss it,
you don't even bother to look at all the work that I do.
Ricky, I don't...
I think that that's unfair.
No, it's not.
Okay, this is unfair.
Talk to mom.
Okay.
No, Ricky, I don't...
I don't want to...
Exactly.
That's exactly the kind of attitude.
And then three weeks later, you come to...
I'm sorry, man.
I'm not supposed to do this.
Huh?
I have a lot of things to do.
I have a lot of responsibilities.
I don't want to get...
No, this is bullshit.
Okay, for you it's bullshit.
It is bullshit.
So you're like, oh, I want you to do the accounting.
I'm not gonna...
You're not gonna understand this.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah.
As if...
As if I haven't been doing...
You know what?
Huh?
Stop and take it back.
Because I don't want to continue this discussion.
No, this is fucking bullshit.
No, no, no.
I can't fucking believe that you would...
I can't even fucking believe that you would say it like that.
I...
It's fucking unbelievable.
You know, we ended up...
I knew that we started talking...
And you ended up talking...
Talking bullshit.
And that's what I do want.
Yeah, you know why?
And I go to the...
Tell me exactly why I'm mad.
Tell me.
Tell me why I'm mad.
Because you think that I don't mind...
That I don't mind what you are doing.
I...
Of course, I do.
No, you don't.
Okay, but stop it.
No.
Okay.
Seriously.
What is the point?
Okay, I don't mind.
That's what I want me to tell you.
Don't mind.
Go to your business.
Do it in the way that you want.
Period.
But I cannot risk my health.
You're risking your own health.
Yes.
I am risking my own health...
With this nonsense.
It's not nonsense.
You know why?
You don't even glance...
At the spreadsheets that I make.
Vicky.
And then you come and preach...
Vicky, you are...
Okay.
You are...
Like, look how much...
Just...
And I don't understand...
Exactly.
You know why?